Chính thăm Trung Quốc của tổng bị thư Chủ Tình nước Toalem được kì vọng sẽ tích được cùng cố tìm cạnh trình trị và mở giọng hợp tắt thử chất giữa Việt Nam và Trung Quốc trong dưới bạn phát triển mới.
Vào sơ khu cường đã học sinh tập Trung gương Trung Quốc cho rằng, khoa nề 2 đạn hài nước, đang bước tật dưới bạn phát triển mới, bởi tận sất tiếp xúc cấp caong ngày càng dày đặc, tưởng bước hình thành tơ trễ gặp cở định kiểu giữa hợp tắt và chết lần cho đổi thông nướng lướng nước cao.
Các chuyến thăm cấp cao thường xuyên không trả rút định lần chế hợp cho quán hệ sông phương, trở mà con có phần cũng có lòng tiến chính trị.
Anh cần kiểm soát mất đồng và tục đẩy hợp đắt thử chất giữa hài nước.
Vậy đối dung trong tâm của chuyến thăm, gióng sơ khu cường nhấn mạnh, bí tế tục trình thay kinh nhận thức chung và phương giữ lướng mà lãnh đạo hài nước đã đạt được.
Các biệt lấy yêu cầu sau hơn trong quanh hệ sông phương, trong đó hợp tắt tình tế tục là chụi cô tôn trọng.
Hãy bây giờ kì vọng sẽ đúng đẩy mạnh mẽ thương mạnh, tăng cường cho đổi thông nè và đẩy nhấn tức dự án kinh đủ hạ tân.
Nhất là tuyến đường sắp lào kai hà nội hài phòng, tên nối với mạng lưỡng sắc chú quốc.
Ở góc đồ của khu vực và khu tế, trên ra chung cuối trời rằng Việt Nam ở Trung Quốc đã phối hợp hiệu qua cho việc tăng cường tình cải chính trị,
tìm xa bất đồng và dưới chi ông định.
Cua đỏ đấm góc tức cửa hoa bình và phát triển của khu vực.
Bởi em họng, giải góc thông quý với nế tạng, tính trị ngay căng được cửa.
Hợp tắc chính trất ngay căng mở giọc và lợi ít gân kết thật chạy.
Quán hệ Việt Nam chục quốc sẽ tiếp tục phát triển của định.
Bình vấn trong thời gian tới.
Theo giống xương câu cường, chuyến đâm Trung Quốc là này của tòm bý tư, chủ tĩnh gốc tốt lâm,
được khi vọng sẽ tức tập làm xong xác hơn, quan hệ đối tá hợp tá chính lực vàn dạc.
Thông đại zây dựng cọng đồng chưa s欸 từng gái, khói nghĩa chính lực rất hành lực.
Bối nền tặng quan hệ hướng nì trên thống và sự tình cải chính trị, ngay căng được cửa,
quan hệ Việt Nam Trung Quốc, được khi vọng sẽ tức t jum phát triển tí cụ, thực chết và bên bống,
Đấm góc cho hoa bình ổn đe và phát triển của cuộc vực vạc thế giới.